machine à remonter le temps n'a pas
encore été inventée mais dans 30 ans se
refait ce sera complètement illégal
seuls des bandes organisées
l'utiliseront mes employeurs dans le
futur quand ils veulent éliminer
quelqu'un ils l'attrapent l'expo dit
dans le passé jusqu'à moi il disparaît
du futur et je suis un homme qui
n'existe pas encore sûr que moi on les
appelle des ou peur mais bien payé
on l'appelle vide on les tire comme tu
es là bas se règle que le type apparaît
c'est d'appuyer sur la détente
facile
jusqu'au jour où celui qui est apparue
et témoin sur fera la règle non sur
fuite
un type du futur lâché trop longtemps
dans la nature c'est dangereux
j'ai perdu ma vie si je le tue je
retrouverai puis se sont plus à faire
qu'est ce que tu attends
cette saloperie de voyage de huit ans a
vite fait de cramer le cerveau
qui maintient cette année ce faire
j'ai pas le choix faut que je me
retrouve à et que je me batte